- The words death, die, and dead
are all likely derived from
the proto Indo-European root
deu which meant to die, faint, or vanish.
It's also where we get the word funeral,
but if you're actually at a funeral,
you probably wouldn't
use any of these words.
It just feels too blunt
to say, sorry he's dead.
When discussing topics that
are sensitive or taboo,
people often employ euphemisms,
words or phrases that replace direct terms
in order to spare feelings,
avoid embarrassment,
or even out of superstition.
And when it comes to
sensitive or taboo topics,
nothing is as universally avoided,
yet universally unavoidable, as death.
So it's got a lot of euphemisms
in virtually every language.
Whether you believe that
you're going somewhere
or getting reincarnated or
will just cease to exist,
you're going to have to
face your own mortality
at some point.
So why not talk about it now?
Euphemistically, of course.
I'm Dr. Erica Brozovksy,
and this is Otherwords.
(whimsical music)
- Otherwords.
- Perhaps the safest
way to talk about death
is to avoid the act of dying altogether
and instead focus on the person's absence.
So you might say they're
gone or no longer with us
or in Mandarin, they're already not here.
If you're religious,
you might attribute
that absence to a deity,
saying they are with the
Lord or summoned by God,
or had Allah take their soul.
Many euphemisms frame death
as a journey or crossing.
You might say someone passed,
departed, slipped away,
or even sprouted wings.
Some sayings even specify the destination.
In China, you can fly on a
crane to the Western paradise.
In America, you can ride to
the happy hunting grounds,
a term for the afterlife
that has been attributed
to Native Americans,
but was more likely made
up by European colonists.
You can meet St. Peter
at the Pearly Gates,
or if you're into Greek mythology,
you can cross the river Styx,
an underworld waterway where
souls would be ferried across
by the boatman, Charon.
And if the deceased is a pet,
they might cross the rainbow bridge,
perhaps an allusion to the Bifrost bridge
of Norse mythology.
- This stupid dog won't die.
- Doors, gates, rivers, and
bridges are common imagery,
highlighting the belief in
a boundary between worlds,
which the deceased would
have to somehow penetrate.
By the way, figures
like Charon or St. Peter
or the Grim Reaper,
whose job is to guide
souls across that boundary
are known as psychopomps,
which is a pretty cool word,
and would also be a great name
for a Neo-rockabilly band.
And speaking of rockabilly,
another departure metaphor
can be traced to The King himself.
To try to get the crowd to
go home after his concerts.
announcers would tell them
that Elvis has left the building.
Ever since he joined the Choir Invisible,
"left the building" has become
a euphemism for dying.
Slumber is another popular
metaphor for death,
which is not surprising since
it's the closest experience
in life we have to relate to.
You can be laid to rest
or take the big sleep.
In Afrikaans, you close
your eyes for the last time,
fall into an eternal dream in Hungarian
and use the earth as
your blanket in Lakota.
That sounds nice. I mean,
who doesn't like sleep?
On the other hand,
you can also take a dirt nap
or sleep with the fishes,
which sound decidedly less pleasant.
These are examples of dysphemisms,
substitutions that are
deliberately blunt or insensitive.
So euphemistically, someone
might breathe their last,
but dysphemistically, that
old geezer down the road
finally bit the dust.
There are a lot of dysphemisms for dying
like croaking or giving up the ghost.
You might use them to celebrate
the expiration of someone
you didn't like,
but they can also serve
a positive function.
To give us a sense of
power over something scary
and confusing.
After all, how can I
be afraid of carking it
when I talk about it so cavalierly?
A popular dysphemism for death in the UK
is popped his clogs,
which means pawned his shoes
because he won't be needing them anymore
and funerals are expensive.
A lot of death metaphors deal
with the things you won't need
or can't use.
According to the Portuguese,
you won't be eating mangoes next season.
You won't be eating anything in fact,
so you may as well stick
your spoon in the wall
and leave your teeth behind.
You can also kick the calendar
because time is a living person's problem
and swallow your birth certificate
because age is irrelevant at this point.
However, the Seediq people of Taiwan
hold out hope for one more meal
because their dead go to plant yams.
But perhaps the most dysphemistic
ways of referring to death
involve the grave.
Six feet under, bought a pine condo,
went into the fertilizer
business, food for worms,
even wearing wooden pajamas.
These sayings ignore the
lofty journeys of the soul,
and instead describe what happens
to your physical body after death.
which let's be honest, isn't pretty.
Some refer to the
position of the body like
belly up, toes up, or
stretching one's legs.
A lot of languages focus on the flowers.
Whether you're pushing
up daisies in English,
raising mallow in Spanish,
looking at daisies from below in Dutch,
smelling flowers from
below in Hebrew and Polish
violets in particular in Hungarian
or eating dandelions
by the roots in French.
These sayings might be oddly specific,
but you could still sort
of guess their meaning
if you'd never heard them before.
This is not true of idioms,
which are phrases whose
origins are now so obscure
that they make no literal sense today.
The most famous English idiom for death
is probably kick the bucket.
Some suggests that this refers to
a particular method of hanging,
but it's more likely that
the bucket of this phrase
is an old term for the wooden beam
that an animal's feet would be
tied to for slaughtering.
Quite a grizzly image to end
up on so many travel blogs.
Another popular idiom is bought the farm.
Again, a widespread and
probably incorrect explanation
claims that test pilots in
World War One used this term
because if you crashed your
plane into a nearby field,
the government would
reimburse the property owner
for the damage,
which could then be used
to pay off the mortgage,
I.E. buy the farm,
but whenever the origin for an idiom
just sounds a little too
tidy, it probably isn't true.
In fact, referring to
death as buying a plot,
predates airplanes by several decades.
So the farm in question is more likely
just a metaphor for the grave,
which you purchase with your life.
Buying the farm and popping your clogs
aren't the only sayings that
frame death as a transaction.
You can also cash in your
chips, get your ticket punched,
and check out.
Humans have long seen death as a time
for squaring up old debts.
In ancient Greece,
mourners would place a coin
in the deceased's mouth
before burial,
so they'd have money to pay the boatman.
Hey, even psychopomps gotta make a living.
It makes sense that we have
so many terms for death
because our feelings about
it are so complicated.
One word was never going
to cover the vast array
of human emotions and experiences
that revolve around it.
We may disagree about what happens
after we've sung our swan song.
Perhaps we'll meet our maker
or maybe we're just plain
brown bread, but at least the debate will be colorful.
A popular dysphemism for death--
A popular dysphemism for death in the UK
is popped his clogs.
A popular--
(laughing)
I was too excited.